-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
And this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're going to
get to the news.
In a living room.
In an apartment owned
by people I've never met.
According to a new survey,
just 9% of Americans said
that the Biden administration
is doing a great job handling
the Omicron coronavirus strain.
I assume it's the same 9%
who don't currently have it.
Oh, you're cocky now.
But it's coming.
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
overall disapproval rating
hit a new high last month,
or as his aides are phrasing it,
"Your numbers are way up, sir."
The CDC is reportedly
considering updating
its coronavirus guidance
to recommend that people
wear N95 or KN95 masks
or, barring that, just 95 masks.
The CDC also issued a
do-not-travel advisory yesterday
for Canada due to an increase
in coronavirus cases there,
which is kind of
like Keith Richards
telling you not to hang around
with that pothead from school.
According to new reports,
Senate Democrats have grown
tired of trying to convince
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin
to support
a federal elections bill
and complained that it's "like
negotiating via Etch A Sketch."
Which begs the question,
have you tried shaking him yet?
The federal government
has reportedly approved Facebook
for hundreds of new patents
over the last few months
for augmented
and virtual reality technology
they've created.
It's great for escaping
this hellish actual reality
which they also created.
The makers of Goldfish have
unveiled a new type of cracker
that's 50% bigger
than the original snack
and specifically made
for adults.
Please, I'm a grown man.
I'm not gonna eat Goldfish.
I just had two string cheeses
and a Fruit Roll-Up,
and my tummy's a mess.
According to a new documentary,
"Playboy" founder
Hugh Hefner's pet poodle
was addicted to cocaine,
though according to my eyes,
all of them are.
That's right, Hugh Hefner's
poodle was addicted to cocaine,
which explains why he was
so afraid of the vacuum cleaner.
"No! My stash!"
Yeah, dogs -- dogs on cocaine
sound like Samberg.
That's just science.
And finally, Tesla recently
released a new version
of its self-driving software
that allows drivers to select
among three different
aggression profiles,
including chill, average,
or New Jersey Turnpike.
And I'm hearing -- Really?
Was the 1 millionth
monologue joke
with the punch line
"New Jersey Turnpike."
Across all talk shows,
since the history of talk shows.
And is that true?
I'm gonna get a $10
E-ZPass credit for that.
So, ha-ha,
things are looking up.